the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay the
the class unfortunately we seem to have
run out of it so if you could share the
syllabus that you have I'm actually not
going to go over it in detail I do want
to give you sort of the big picture of
what we're doing first of all I'm glad
you're here and I and I do want class
participation there will be three
problem sets and a research proposal the
the problem sets are meant to be
practice for you just to make sure
you're working through the material some
of you take field exams for example so
these problem sets are meant to be
practices for that as well it's really
meant to help you one of the problem
sets is going to focus on actually
getting your hands dirty with the data
so to speak and what's going to help
with that and give you access to these
towns and high data and and and we'll
have a specific project you're around
that it's it's really a research class
so I would like you to write a research
proposal
not exactly a paper it can be short but
the idea is that hopefully as we go
through these lectures you will and I
will try to help this process you'll
have ideas about things you would like
to work on things where you think the
literature is falling short and you
should begin to sort of think about that
it's it's all too easy in these courses
to think that taking a course means
memorizing the lecture notes or learning
how to manipulate as in a certain model
and not thinking you know broadly about
next steps you don't see faculty doing
the research actually I'm going to try
to share with you how literature's
develop compare and contrast different
styles different attack strategies in
fact the lectures are going to be a
blend between overview material and the
usual detailed analysis of specific
papers but because that's a big part of
the course I want you to get some
experience at trying to think about
things that way as well the syllabus
does say something about a midterm which
is basically the final for my half of
the course this is joint with object but
my first gift to you is that we're going
to waive that so there will be no final
exam and instead the emphasis is going
to be on the problem sets and the
research proposal and and class
participation before I forget to say the
recitation section is scheduled
Thursdays I had originally thought it
was Friday's so we put to be determined
in all those recitation sections and in
fact by this Thursday noon just after
this class essentially you would have
already had your first recitation
section but it's just too early so we're
not going to meet on Thursday but we
will start in earnest to fall in a week
and if you start looking at the syllabus
you will see that there's a section at
the beginning on data which I've kind of
already mentioned there's a section at
the beginning on computation and also on
the GIS so if you want to think about
those as tools or skills
we're gonna have some TA sessions going
over sort of some of the computational
aspects for example after the lecture on
Thursday though it will be obvious how a
computational recitation section fits in
now I recognize you know I don't want to
overdo this but the more I've talked to
many of you the more including yesterday
actually in some sense and advising of
second years the more I realized that
students like you want to get trained in
computational skills and methods and so
on so we can have some extra sessions
I'm in the busy and the were in the
process of setting up extra
computational sections on how to solve
certain problems we'll probably make up
for the lost TA session on Thursday and
and when in fact it's going to send out
an email to each of you to try to work
on scheduling a backup time so if we
have some extra sessions we'll try to
have as few conflicts as possible so so
you can come so I guess the only thing I
want to say about the syllabus that
won't be obvious from the lecture is
today is the introductory class and
[Music]
there's all this supplementary material
and then on Thursday we'll start with
lecture two you'll get a dose of these
sort of micro founded macro models we're
going to go on to another sort of new
wave of those models featuring limited
commitment and collateral constraints on
the growth TFP type issues and then
another section focuses on basically
versions where there's costly state
verification or moral hazard or adverse
selection so so you can compare and
contrast the implications of having
these different financial underpinnings
which you know is complementary classes
in macro are also getting getting at
those same issues then we'll have sort
of the intermediate class on micro data
and building all the way from household
accounts to national income accounts and
then move to actually using the micro
data for various tests of these models
full insurance in various ways and
with these obstacles to trade and and
and so on throughout the class so that's
that's kind of the big picture of the of
the syllabus each lecture is pretty a
lot of fun and there's a lot of material
in there the lecture notes are meant as
I've said to tie the material together
both in general and and in its specifics
today is a little bit of an exception
because it's just a an introductory
lecture I will try to have all the
slides posted I'm not sure we managed to
get this thing posted but I'll do that
I'll try to get that done right after
class normally the slides will be posted
in advance of the class so if you feel
more comfortable looking at material
might facilitate asking questions during
class which would be good oh good
excellent okay and most of the readings
are linked not entirely all of them so
it should be easy to explore you know
your special topic are there questions
about the logistics of the class and
I'll hang around a bit afterwards to
answer any any specific questions you
might have
okay so finance growth and volatility
theory data and the formulation of
policy you know the course is organized
around these topics there's so many ways
to to think about this finance financial
access is a very huge issue in
development you may be more used to
thinking about it from a micro
perspective but we not only do the micro
we do the macro the idea is that somehow
finance helps people with financial
services that may be alleviated in
poverty and in the context of these
general equilibrium models it has
additional effects so many countries
around the world not just the World Bank
and other
eight agencies are pushing promoting
advocating financial access there's new
Gallup survey is measuring this stuff to
try to get at inequalities across
countries to sort of push a little bit
the agenda
so that's financing growth I'm going to
say more in a second finance and
volatility sort of should bring to mind
the recent US and worldwide financial
crisis and it pushes you seemingly in
exactly the opposite direction which is
you know maybe the housing market in the
u.s. maybe there was a little too much
effort for middle or even lower income
households to own homes and that's led
to certain you know government agency
financing arrangements and and in any
event it clearly was a financial crisis
and most of the regulations deal with
you know seemingly trying to push us
back toward more restricted
intermediation as if financial access
and credit and financial liberalisation
might if not be a bad thing you know
maybe go too far well we're gonna try to
be writing down models that think about
not only each of those separately but to
some extent having it on the same page
to try to get at that tension and
actually growth is in there with
financing growth growth and volatility
is another quote bilateral pairing if
you wish there's some idea that finance
causes growth but growth does not come
with out volatility you know leaving the
question I just raised about financial
ball
finance and voluntati so let me sort of
give you a sense of
each of these sub pieces finance and
growth well here's the story and I think
it's pretty well accepted by these these
three papers for example that are very
much cited King and Levine Rajan is an
galas and in Ross Levine you can read
the abstract but basically let's pick
out a few things here financing growth
shrimp être might be right cross country
evidence that financial systems promote
growth that the levels of financial
development are strongly associated with
per-capita GDP growth and capital
accumulations and improvements in
efficiency like TFP but furthermore
there seems to be causality in the data
that predetermined level of financial
dpa deepening or development are
associated with subsequent higher rates
of all these good things Rajan and
Singhal is come at it in a in a related
way they're basically saying that
industrial sectors that are more in need
of external finance due to the nature of
the business develop disproportionately
faster starting from a lower level in
countries where the financial systems
are liberalized or more liberal than in
other countries and they're worried
about causality and so forth and the
Levine's review finance and growth
theory and evidence some the summary in
the abstract with qualifications to
follow from him countries with better
functioning banks grow faster but
however doesn't seem to matter whether
it's Bank led finance source or stocks
or equity markets he tries to cover the
literature on simultaneity bias
and so on so Levine also points out the
importance of this question and the
importance therefore to research and I
must say in these slides I tried to
indicate where there were quotes but at
some point you may find it hard to tell
what was the author's statement which is
quite clear here versus my my summary
but I wanted to see I want I didn't want
you to have to take my word for it I
actually wanted you to see what these
guys are saying in their papers research
that clarifies our understanding of the
role of finance and economic growth have
policy implications and shape policy
oriented research this is going to
influence the priority that policymakers
and advisors attach to reforming the
financial service sector and so when
this empirical work shows there's a
connection between finance and long-run
growth that basically advertises the
urgent need for research on the
political legal regulatory or policy
determinants of financial development
note he's not saying that it's done deal
and he has been one of the lead
contributors to this empirical work but
he's saying in fact there's much more to
do on the research side specific policy
implications are not immediate it's not
obvious how to go from the general idea
of policy to the way that financial
systems actually work and in particular
the way they are modeled at the
theoretical level so you'll see this
over and over again in these lectures
which is this and I try to bring out
both sides which is empirical work seems
to mesmerize if not reassure theoretical
work with almost no mention to the data
and often this gap in between I'm gonna
try to bridge the gap show you how the
literature is trying to bridge the gap
but it's kind of reassuring and
refreshing to see Levine being so candid
in this rather famous review article he
says what a financial intermediaries
really do well you can think about
producing information about investment
possibilities or monitoring investments
maybe corporate governance is better if
they're somebody looking at them
facilitate trading facilitate
diversification is important when
there's risk for sure and the management
of that risk financial systems at a
theoretical level mobilized in pool
savings and generally ease the exchange
of goods and services so changes in
these functions that are brought about
by say policy changes you know could
influence savings and investment and
therefore have influence on economic
growth now then you start to think about
what is he really saying or not saying
one thing that sort of caught my
attention and I was predisposed to look
for it is this distinction about levels
versus growth rates so is his vision one
of steadily improving financial
intermediation on one or several of
these dimensions pushing levels of
income up so that an expanding improved
financial sector over time is causing
growth in the sense that you have
ever-increasing levels or is he saying
that a once-and-for-all
fixed to the financial system making it
go from a load or a higher level and no
changes after that have an implication
for sustained growth as in quote steady
state not clear from what he said
and we'll see models that take both
these tacks actually there are other you
know sort of caveats when you think
about theoretical modeling are we
talking about technological improvement
in the sense of TFP is that really what
improved intermediation is supposed to
be giving us but again we should maybe
think also about transitions or even
potentially poverty traps if if systems
get get stuck another caveat savings
rates are not monotone with increases in
return I mean for one thing in price
theory just think about income and
substitution effects you know one cuts
against the other one or what about the
relationships between savings and
improved allocation of risk if you
improve the allocation of risk bearing
then you don't need to save as a buffer
stock so savings may actually go down
and not up as a consequence of improving
one piece of the financial system and
then he makes his pitch for thinking
about don't think broadly about savings
or especially credit as an input think
about actually how the financial system
is is put together and we'll come back
to that especially when we get to the
measurement part does finance cause
reduced inequality he said in this
review not necessarily
and he reviews empirical evidence there
are theoretical models that claim this
to be true that the relationship is say
favorable to reduce property reduce
inequality and so on but certainly in
some of the theoretical models and some
of them were that we're going to cover
improved financial systems at least
early on cause increases in inequality
not decreases
in inequality something along the lines
of what Kuznetsov in mind actually and
then he just goes through some empirical
work and doesn't come back not to
belittle it but he does he does not come
back to this underlying tension okay
volatility and growth let's see you know
before we start thinking that all the
volatility we see has something to do
with finance or unstable financial
systems maybe we should try to document
better those sources so this paper in
the queue je is a decomposition of the
sources of inequality looking in
particular at low-income countries take
it as a fact I'll show you a graph
momentarily from them that there is more
volatility in growth rates among
low-income countries and why is that
happening
could be that poor countries somehow or
other end up specialized in volatile
sectors or it could be a version of that
they just have a lot more quote
specialization and they're not you know
terribly diversified over a multitude of
different sectors could be that poor
countries experienced more frequent or
more severe aggregate shocks sort of
from a macro policy perspective and it's
even possible that poor countries
experience macro fluctuations that are
somehow correlated with the shocks in
which their the sectors in which they're
specialized
so here's the picture this is levels of
per capita GDP and and the variance
standard deviation calculation this
morning sort of thinking about this
lecture I spooked myself a bit worrying
that it should have been growth rates
and not levels but but actually when
they when they do the analysis they do a
composition in the growth of value-added
again I can't do justice to this paper
other than give you an overview but what
they're saying is that the growth of GDP
per worker and country J this object
here is a weighted average of the growth
of GDP in the various sectors in which
country J is is specialized and these
Ajay's are the weights one of the
proportions and then they write down a
quite plausible statistical model that
the growth of value-added GDP per worker
in sector J of country s has a country S
component a sector J component and some
some residual so that's kind of the
basic model and what they do then is a
very clever basically
variance-covariance decomposition
quantifying and answering the questions
that were raised on the on the previous
slide
the answer is sixty percent of this
volatility is country specific so I
don't know how you want to think about
that it's not even fifty-fifty more than
half of it is somehow a country's
specific phenomenon on the other hand
there's a very non-trivial residual
forty percent almost 50 say which is
which is due to the following namely
diversification is limited in low-income
countries and low-income countries do
tend to specialize in sectors that are
are relatively volatile
you know it sets aside the issue of why
and whether there are any possible
remedies and so on a model in which
volatility is inevitable this is one of
Jerome's models with Zilla Botti it's a
great paper and the idea is simple but
very clever which is basically there's a
fixed cost to opening up a new sector
and at any moment in time of course you
have a limited amount of resources so
you've got to choose you you can't
literally afford to do everything you
can only do a subset of things so you're
naturally vulnerable to two shocks in
technologies that can't cover your that
that are not able to cover your risk now
within that there are some policy issues
we might come back to at some point but
for a while clearly these countries are
going to just be more volatile because
they're less able to divert - to
diversify then it gets a little more
what should I say
provocative which is maybe volatility is
actually not something you'd like to get
rid of and eventually can afford to do
it maybe it's actually a necessary
ingredient for growth in other words if
we come back to the big motivation the
idea that finance causes growth okay
let's do it
and finance and macro stability well
maybe you're gonna have the downside of
that that there has to be some
instability if you're going to get the
growth I mean if you think this is
entirely provocative just think about
the mean variance idea of holding assets
you don't get a higher mean for free
higher means come with more risk
so we should maybe take this seriously
as did these authors I think this is in
the q je and they they documented
countries that have had occasional
financial crises do grow faster on
average how do they measure that
basically risk idea well they don't want
to take a simple variance measure
because that's like small or big left or
right tail it doesn't matter they're
trying to get at a crisis so their idea
is look at the growth of credit or
actually quite negative growth when you
have a bust
first the boom may be inching along
maybe a trend who knows how fast but
occasionally lam you get one of these
episodes where the bottom falls out and
I can't help but say it's a bit odd that
since the US had a recent financial
crisis everyone's kind of tearing up all
the old work and starting over as if we
need a whole new agenda whereas
countries throughout the world for
Rogoff would say hundreds of years have
been experiencing financial crises so
certainly we should pay attention not to
say something's good or bad but there's
lots of historical experience so they
look at the skewness of of credit growth
I always get the sign wrong that
positive basically puts the mass in the
left tail and they actually have a
little model which I'll come back to in
a second so here are some pictures India
versus Thailand
real credit growth and GDP growth so the
dotted line is Thailand which you know
way back to 1980 was expanding its
financial system that's measured by real
credit
and then this is the famous if not
infamous infamous financial crisis that
started in July 2nd 1997 when the Bank
of Thailand realized it couldn't
continue to hold the exchange rate and
because they had forward commitments
they seem to have forgot about and that
spread as you know too many not all but
many of the Asian countries not even
nearby countries I mean Korea is not
near but they too suffered however if
you look at the and India did not have
this crisis and India's been bragging a
lot lately how clever they were to be
conservative that they did not suffer
from the US financial episode the way
some other countries have had but if you
look at the big picture here at least up
through Oh - you can see Thailand has
it's kind of this v-shaped drop and then
it's right back on I you know my
measurements show that the growth rate
was only 4% after as opposed to 5 or 6%
before so maybe there was a structural
shift but you know this little drop
doesn't affect the overall level India's
level remains lower so during this
period you know country Thailand was one
of the fastest growing countries in the
world you hear a lot about China now and
rightly so India actually also but this
is a big and I didn't realize that these
guys had focused on Thailand we have a
lot more to say about Thailand in the
class but obviously we're not alone in
thinking about Thailand relative to
other countries now whether I agree with
them about the financial crisis is or
that dip is another story but ok now how
does their model work actually the paper
uses this as motivation and then goes on
to try to work out how you would find
countries experiencing these periodic
financial crises
so the idea is it's a credit constraint
model so there are borrowing constraints
like collateral constraints and if they
were locked in place without any
leniency you'd have high returned
businesses starved for credit but what
happens is people begin to anticipate
that actually they can be more generous
in their lending because of the moral
so-called moral hazard problem which is
the government's going to bail them out
so bail out the private sectors so this
is sort of a political economy story
there's kind of like sort of a political
economy driven boom-bust cycle now again
I don't have the equations here but the
papers online and and you can you can
read through their model so they're
saying crises are costly they're
associated with bankruptcies and a
deadweight loss and it's true that when
the crisis happens you get this
depressing effect on new credit and on
investment and hampering growth which
you know it's a big conversation and in
the US and actually to some extent in
Europe and and they're saying if their
model is right or they believe they're
right that these this sort of effect is
going to be larger in countries where
the contract enforceability issues are
more severe like borrowing constraints
on the other hand not too severe if
otherwise they won't get this leverage
effect so then we come to this trilogy
which is finance and volatility we did
finance and growth growth and volatility
now finance and
volatility and I don't have too much
more to say about this other than to
offer the reminder that that awesome Oh
blue paper in the Ron Sierra a towel
paper suggests that volatility might
diminish over time as countries have
higher and higher level of output but as
I said at the beginning in fact not all
these sort of it must be more than a
bunch it must be more than sort of the
transitivity if a is associated with B
and B is associated with C then a should
be associated with C and in the data it
doesn't go that way so clearly there's
something being left out here this paper
which I became aware of more recently
and and they
to find that in fact deeper financial
systems are associated with lower
volatility but and I checked this again
this morning they also have in the
regression the levels of grow of income
and the growth rates of income so so in
other words they have to control for the
other parts of the trilogy basically and
then eke out this effect you know
countries that are poor are often
dependent on trade there are you know
problems when exchange rates move there
there are issues about evaluations and
so on so they they kind of have to
control for all of that and then you
know offer the suggestion that that
finance might be be a good thing but
believe me countries don't know I mean
there the IMF really doesn't know either
and they're very interested in the state
of the literature and in further
research to try to find out because they
have client countries who want to know
what to do they go to the IMF for
example to get advice so so then we come
to this sort of policy discussion that's
going on today
and to be candid it seems to basically
sort of depart from this literature from
both the theoretical and the empirical
literature Levine writes a new paper now
called regulating finance and regulators
to promote growth it's like well we got
to fix the problem we know the financial
crisis was caused by back rent bad
regulation so let's jump in and regulate
somehow or provide the right incentives
so you know how important is it that the
operation of how important is the
operation of the financial system for an
economic growth and which financial
regulatory reforms will improve
financial sector operation he's sort of
assuming in some sense an answer that
the other literature ISM and his own
review was sort of much more equivocal
about
this is another example this Thorton
Beck's work which is highly regarded I
think in policy circles and the idea is
to come up with a financial
possibilities frontier so and again this
is driven by the idea that we're gonna
give countries specific recommendations
they want to know where they stand
you know relative to two other countries
and what if anything they should be
doing so here's the idea you know this
is the say the financial possibilities
frontier this country isn't on it so
somehow they should move up there this
country B actually has a higher level of
financial depth than a but rather than
rest on their sort of levels the idea is
that if we knew what this frontier was
it would tell us they're actually
further below the frontier than a was
they have kind of more ground to go to
get up to that frontier and and then
this'll cat get your eye here beyond the
frontier so the idea is that some
countries are just basically too deep
and they should pull back yeah yeah so
this is basically a huge sort of cross
country regression with tons of X
variables I mean the next slide has you
know give you some sense there are
variables in there to try to control
somehow for institutions they're surveys
of sort of you know how good it how easy
it is to conduct business in these
countries they're other things
associated with structural problems
there's even you know policy stuff
although honestly I don't remember we
can look it up and see you know sort of
categorize all the X variables now I'm
somewhat sympathetic to looking at data
so we don't want to say this is you know
completely uninformative and and I am
sympathetic with the idea that knowing
that what has happened to different
countries at different points in times
might kind of give us pause like leading
indicators there's a whole group
actually I was talking to to Ken
singleton the other day and I don't
think this this work is quite public yet
but but they're the ideas you know he's
in finance and a very good person and
he's trying to measure the risk premium
based on observed asset prices and and
and they seem to be showing that when
the risk premium is low that's when you
run into trouble and that might sound
like counterintuitive at first but the
point is if the markets are saying or
understating the amount of risk then you
can imagine the financial system is just
pumping too much money into otherwise
risky things and that's when countries
run into trouble event
so so it's good to have our Lee warnings
that's good but that seems to me you
know the challenge here is to to get
beneath the frontier in fact I find the
whole jargon a bit misleading because
there's a utility possibilities frontier
which is like the bread and butter of
general equilibrium economics at one
point is you can't get beyond the
frontier anyway there's a question
that's me so this is one instance where
my thoughts kind of merge into heck is
to his so I'm the one worried about prey
optimality
[Music]
to construct a parade or a utility
possibilities frontier we need to
specify the model we're gonna have to
layout preferences endowments and
Technology we're gonna have to take a
stand on possible imperfections in the
credit and financial system and just say
that you know sometimes it will turn out
that despite limited commitment or some
information problems it's a well defined
notion and markets should allow you to
end up on the frontier but there are
other things like pecuniary
externalities where if there's no you
know remedy then you you could end up
off the frontier too due to an
externality so the Clos something close
to the same language works but your if
I'm understanding you correctly they're
not say they're not representative
consumer models typically they they have
all the heterogeneity in them and there
are issues about whether there is a
pseudo representative consumer that
somehow approximates the behavioral so
those are key issues in these models and
and most of them don't aggregate up that
way but on the other hand we can look at
the welfare implications and finally
there's this paper an IMF working paper
on how to deal with credit booms and
this seems to be a summary of the
current consensus I hesitate to call it
that that credit booms buttress
investment and consumption they can
contribute to long-run deepening but
they often end up in costly balance
sheet dis allocations and dislocations
and and more often than acceptable in
devastating financial crises whose cost
too greatly exceeds the benefit
associated with the boom so this is the
view somehow
that that is pretty typical and so you
end up with this sort of goal to keep an
eye on financial liberalisation x' to
limit credit expansion somehow although
they don't quite know how and the menu
of things that they're looking at you
know is very Bassel like they're
basically ad hoc international best
practice statements as if it were
obvious you know how to regulate the
financial system those regulations are
not coming from fundamental
considerations of how credit markets
work and how they interact with the
macro economy so is there another way an
alternative approach
I guess it's self-evident from what I've
been saying in this introduction is to
understand something I'm going to refer
to short handedly as apply general
equilibrium development economics to
understand the unit of analysis at which
this can be applied and to clarify what
that is relative to other general
equilibrium models in the literature so
so this may be familiar if shocking
picture so to speak in the context if
you haven't seen it before this is a
picture of of a village in India you
know we can enumerate the household by
their wealth order them by their their
wealth and look at the years where panel
data were gathered in these so-called a
Chrisette villages this is our a poly
and here you can see the ups and downs
of income ok idiosyncratic aggregate
risk you know there's not a lot of coal
movement here you know the peaks are
covering up the valleys behind it
households are not having up and ups and
downs together there's plenty of risk
in the system and this is how the
consumption picture turns out you know I
often refer to this in a shorthand way
as the Rocky Mountains versus Kansas in
Kansas is pretty boring it's very flat
and but what it shows you very
dramatically is it somehow someway in
these village economies they have
figured out a way to smooth a lot of the
risk in fact they come very close not
totally there but very close to
achieving the optimal allocation of risk
bearing that that arrow arrow debreu and
so on have been talking about now you
know don't dismiss this as okay okay
we're back in thank God its development
we're back in villages the point is the
point is that you can use this framework
and the data are available to do this
not just at the village level
collections of villages regions in a
country or even across countries and
every single one of those things is done
and there's a huge literature so we know
quite a bit about the allocation of risk
bearing in fact we're where systems fail
here's another put look at sort of an
economy this turns out to be another
village and it's about the
diversification issue so if you could do
all this great expose smoothing somehow
you should just specialize in what
you're good at and you know your asset
Holdings might appear pretty specialized
and maybe the bulk of your consumption
is determined expose by borrowing and
lending and gift-giving and whatever
else they're doing but no not in
medieval England they they divided up
their land in an extraordinary way a
typical farmer would have 60 or 70 plots
fragmented throughout the village this
is also true in Bolivia up and keep Leno
and so on running down different
elevations so the point here is not all
economies are alike not even all
villages are alike and you know sort of
looking at data in this case partly
through this institution you can see
that the ex post allocation of
risk-bearing
must you know evidently be more limited
in this case a took a private
information model to try to explain that
outcome again to reassure you that this
is not just macro its macro development
macro Devo devoted to macro or I don't
know you can turn that any way you want
someone made a joke once a day you know
if if if in this lives you don't have a
picture of a villager or something then
you're not really a development
economist I actually I took this picture
but so you got land labor and capital
okay so I love villages and the reason
is you really don't have to make things
up you can actually measure things and
get an approximate sense of what what
the preference the endowments and
Technology our preferences are a bit
trickier so that's the way the language
we use as general equilibrium theorists
you know preferences endowments
technology as I said in answer to the
earlier question and then you can do
this kind of adding up so this is like
taking these villages the Thai villages
and adding up all the households in the
village where the financial counts we'll
get to that in a minute that's the
measurement part the midpoint of the
course and you can see in one region
near Bangkok you know village output
P except it's not national is going down
and the other regions it's kind of going
up this is a second panel so to speak is
whether savings is put into real or
financial investments and here you have
the balanced payments so it shouldn't be
too much of a stretch to realize that if
you have the measurement you can indeed
zoom in and zoom out you can go from
households out to the whole country and
intermediate steps in between and use
these standard tools in this case we've
ended up with the tools that
international economists use and we can
I'm using them internally within the
country but at least if the measurement
is in common we are allowed to do that
I'll just pause briefly to talk about
the data I've already mentioned we have
it and you should feel free to use it
it's quite extensive it's 15 years worth
of data and some of its monthly it's
both rural and urban yeah I'm in city
neighborhoods and and spread out
throughout the kingdom
this is zooming in and zooming out
literally so here you can see almost
like an aerial photo with the village
locations where we collect data you know
zoom all the way over here you can see
zooming way out you know where it is
basically it's somewhat near Bangkok
this particular sample site and this is
sort of the intermediate level here
we're plotting at the level of provinces
the wealth level which is in common with
those two diagrams well we have this
extensive GIS system I've made a
campaign of putting all available
secondary data that I could get a hold
of over the years a lot of it's
available through dataverse Harvard MIT
and
and we are in the process of putting
this onto this common GIS platform where
you can look at bank locations and
factory locations and Road networks and
compute travel time and so on so one of
the if you're interested I can have my
GIS person maybe have a special session
and and sort of show you a little bit
about how to use the system and and the
kind of work does that's possible to do
with it
it's coming there isn't that much work
in economics that has explicit sort of
general equilibrium spatial modeling but
it's coming so it it's a wide-open and
interesting research topic so what is
this general equilibrium development
approach well it's not just individual
maximization it's not just partial
equilibrium its general equilibrium so
things like the economy wide interest
rate and wage rates are very much on our
minds from a development perspective
it's not just the impact of some savings
account or improved credit product on
individuals it's about efficiency of the
system in other words it's not just on
the credit side it's kind of on the
lending side the money for lending comes
from savings have to think about
intermediation and the flow of funds and
judge efficiency using this Pareto quiet
criterion it's not a foregone conclusion
what the best-fitting market or contract
structure is that's something that comes
out of the analysis that's why it's so
good to have the micro data because you
can actually test you could have village
of one village doing quite well and a
whole region in another part of the
country doing doing terribly but we
don't have to guess or assume
because we'll in the course you know
acquire some tools for doing that
analysis so clearly it's not the ever
varying Washington Consensus which is
for liberalisation and now for
regulation I mean look at Europe just
going back and forth not knowing what to
do that's too high we need to restrain
it oh my god we need the stimulus so we
think through those things at the same
time with these models and I don't mean
to be saying it's all about the u.s.
obviously it's about India it's about
the Philippines its Kenya where they are
allowing cellphones as opposed to
Thailand where they're effectively
ruling it out so you know those are the
debates that are happening in in
developing countries you've got some
stuff on the website if you want to see
I will be tracking Thailand a lot but
I've also been writing a book on Mexico
and you'll see me throw in some slides
like I think the danger here is you see
too much Thailand and then you begin to
think it's all about Thailand well a I'm
not the only one worrying about Thailand
but be you know seeing other countries
and seeing the same analysis done in two
different countries really brings this
stuff to light so that's why Mexico is
sometimes paired in these slides so the
goal here is to explain yes to
understand what's out there but it's
also normative to try to come up with
policies that allow more inclusive
financial systems if the data indicate
that but also to think about the overall
efficiency and to think about market
design and optimal regulation there is
some logic in all of this basically you
assume something or several things you
go out there and test it may fit if it
does fit you've understood sort of the
financial contracts and the imperfection
if it's full information for
we sharing then you know we have this
wonderful standard and it's clear at
least at the village level in India
shouldn't be intervening with particular
households on the other hand if you
reject maybe it's due to a moral hazard
problem the problem that people don't
repay and they walk away from their
investments the data can help indicate
that now then the question is is it all
still constrained it may be its second
best optimal maybe this first best
standard is an illusion but maybe when
its second best things like allowing
more goods to play the role as
collateral like changing the legal
system those kinds of reforms might
might be indicated now there is a lot of
general equilibrium literature to sort
of contrast with this general
equilibrium development point of view
this goes way back to the foundations of
general equilibrium herb scarf and his
students Chauvin and Wally
that's called apply general equilibrium
and does not allow uncertainty this type
of modeling is still used although it's
in kind of pockets it's used within the
world bank all our climate guys over
here at MIT use this stuff that's the
basic conceptual framework the cge model
that lies behind all these conclusions
about how climate change is going to
influence the economy so it is it is it
is quite widely used and there's some
great review articles and it does have
some key strengths computable general
equilibrium has has this strength of
drawing on the national income and
product accounts and input-output
matrices that's just basically the
successor to the supply general
equilibrium
and then we have the more macro like if
I could say so dynamic stochastic
general equilibrium models so you
associate this with Prescott for example
and real business cycles so it's great
on dynamics it's great and being very
clear about shocks
however we anticipated this it largely
assumes a representative consumer as if
you know you had complete markets that
allow this kind of gorman aggregation
with certain preferences so in that
world you're not going to have
redistributed wealth effects and and it
is kind of interesting in sort of a
history of thought point of view that
the despite the early battles in macro
this you know DSGE stuff basically took
over and and largely without modeling
the financial sector and so I think
that's why people felt rather
flat-footed when the financial crisis
you know came along so there is stuff
sort of dynamic general equilibrium
models of the that started with Bernanke
and Gertler I keep looking at help over
there because I know that you know we
feature that just now in the macro
lecture it is kind of built on micro
underpinnings and a certain you know
view of a costly state verification as
an underlying imperfection it does
feature a lot the role of credit and a
financial accelerator but largely with
some exceptions I'll say momentarily
this stuff is an aggregate of model and
it's quite elaborate as a model you have
the central bank you have households
entrepreneur
but entrepreneurs are somehow different
from retailers and we tech retailers are
somehow different from capital goods
producers and certainly in early
versions of Christiano and I can bomb
and so on they actually only look at the
aggregates generated by that model they
never they never assign these sectors to
data it's not tested it's not part of
the the way they're doing business so
maybe they don't need to if they get the
aggregates right but this is a picture
of India this stuff is used by central
banks if you want to see one in Brazil
that's called Samba or something I'm not
sure if that's the music or they have
one it's on the reading list but you
know I must say in a bit more optimistic
vein things are starting to come and
together Shea and clean Al wrote papers
on India and China and on the
distribution of firm size and now it's
almost becoming standard that if you
write down one of these models you have
to look at the implication for firm size
or some key parameter in the model it's
going to be calibrated against the
distribution of firm sizes in the US for
example just like Rajan and Zingales
kind of started dead that research path
so the latest sort of Larry paper you
know definitely uses that and uses other
financial variables starting to look at
bankruptcy and so on so so one can be
somewhat optimistic that these seemingly
similar in the sense of general
equilibrium but obviously diverse
attacks on how the financial system work
were isn't even necessarily modelled
they're kind of coming together and and
I think the place where it arguably has
come together the fastest and and where
we really quite understand quite a lot
is in development economics
and and it features you know the
measurement at the household level using
corporate accounts this is again the
midpoint of the of the series of
lectures so we can get at TFP
productivity change wealth rates of
return treating households just like the
firm's are treated in corporate
financial accounts the income statement
balance sheet statement of cash flow
occupation choice is a key ingredient in
these models because typically in
developing countries you see households
making transitions that used to be in
agriculture they set up a firm maybe
become wage earners so that's a big part
of almost almost all of the models
there's tests of these micro
underpinnings I listed a few papers here
there's some warning that underpinnings
do matter that things are rarely it's
it's rare that one kind of underpinning
is a stand-in for the other ones or at
least it does does not always work out
that way and Matsuyama paper is a pretty
good reminder well actually he more says
things aren't monotonic and Boyd and
Smith and Gertler and Rogoff have
examples of how these underpinnings
really matter to to the macro or
regional phenomenon so so part of part
of the agenda here is measurement and
it's not just measurement at the
household level it's it moves from the
national income accounts and balance
sheets and so on to differences of
balance sheet so it's essentially the
flow of funds you know so if there's one
thing that seems obvious you know but
actually remains challenging is that if
you wanted the model the financial
system in a country should look at the
flow of funds data because that really
tells you at least at the level of
aggregation
it's presented in the public data you
know what financial instruments are
actually used who's taking you know the
debtor lender position in those
instruments you can certainly see very
well with financial with flow of funds
the movement in and out of the formal
financial system because that's where
the measurement is the best actually
because banks have to report stuff they
try desperately to hide a lot but at
least you know flow of funds in and out
of the banking system is available even
for for low income countries
turns out the IMF is loaded with data
people at the fund haven't been using it
but now it's sort of an awakening that
there's a lot of things that could be
done with flow of funds data and I'm in
touch with those guys so potentially if
you were interested in a particular
country you know you get you the latest
flow of funds data you have to keep an
eye on things though in the sense of the
informal sector is typically not
measured but in these countries can be
really key especially in low-income
countries and unfortunately you don't
usually get the geography although we've
had some projects we've encouraged with
Mexico and kind of working with Brazil
to get the geography in there so we'll
come back to this flow of funds diagram
but it basically makes the point that
you can talk about
here is actually a village again with
the transactions of the village with a
sort of not-for-profit corporation
financial corporations non-financial
corporations and and government and so
on so just to belabor the point again
the way that you measure in principle is
common and then you can zoom in and out
you know depending on what you think
might be key and take a look at the
orders of magnitudes of things you may
not realize it but I'm basically
following the order of the syllabus so
after we get through the measurement
part including flow of funds we'll talk
specifically about micro level tests of
insurance of credit this is too
complicated for today but we'll get into
these obstacles to trade and how to test
whether it's a moral hazard problem or
adverse selection problem test
incomplete markets against information
constrained markets this is a lot of
material and I'll be mindful of that
I'll least try to give you some examples
of how this analysis is is being
conducted and we end up back with apply
general equilibrium development
economics which is going to be you know
what we're going to do in class starting
on Thursday we're going to start with
we've already got to reduce
the patient choice models there are
several Banerjee Newman galore and Zahra
Lloyd Ellison burned and Bernhardt
arguing in Bolton
you
the
key parameters of the financial
underpinning
you
we will
lecture of the class we will be sort of
having all the ingredients to micro the
estimation and simulation this is
another sort of genre in the literature
this is financial this one takes the
expansion of the financial system as
exogenous this one tries to make it
endogenous key contributors are say for
example Greenwood ng Ivanovitch Benson
Inca and Smith entirely theoretical
models basically in the style of Ross
Levine taking a stand on how
intermediation works showing you know
for example that inequality might go up
before it goes down but not taken
seriously enough in the sense of going
to the data which is what you know we'll
talk about next time I said quite a bit
during the lecture about policy and
assessing policy so you know Thailand
for example as you saw had financial
deepening going on and at times rather
substantial financial deepening once we
have these models and we've kind of
estimated or calibrated the key
parameter we can do these welfare
experiments we can actually say what
would a why it benefited and for that
matter who lost from the expansion of
the financial system
you know the beneficiaries are like
these poor credit constrained households
that don't have access to the financial
system but over time as they exogenously
are allowed to enter that system they
have huge increases in their welfare and
well-being why does somebody lose
well that growth of enterprise means
increased employment it's pressure on
wages in the model and in Thailand the
real wage eventually shoots up rather
dramatically that increases the cost of
doing business and the profits of
entrepreneurs can drop so so this is
the the wonderful part now I don't mean
to say this model is wonderful it has a
lot of limitations which I will share
with you on Thursday
but what's wonderful about it is that
you can actually go through these
distributive you know welfare gains and
losses types of calculations this one
with endogenous financial deepening
comes back to my comment on the slide
which had India versus Thailand and I
said something obscure about I had
another view of what happened in
Thailand well part of that growth was
preceded by a real flat GDP when you're
basically flatlined and what was going
on well they had certain interest rate
restrictions on you know deposit rates
and lending rates there was an oil shock
you know prices were going up and money
was flowing out of the of the financial
system the banks ran into trouble the
government essentially took them over
and the economy goes flatline you should
worry about this you know it's not
necessarily the case that quote
regulation or you know in this case
national almost close to nationalization
of the banking system is necessary
necessarily the way to deal with the
financial crisis now how on earth are we
able to model this it's really quite
simple
we just create a wedge in the original
greenwood and Jovanovic model which is
the spread between the borrowing and
lending rate and we say when the more
the sorry this sounds very market
oriented the more the government does
the more resources get squandered and
that you know that in efficiency wedge
kind of increases over and above the
cost of intermediation and that the
calibrated parameters that's actually
enough for the model simulation to go
flat but likewise then we can liberalize
the system which Thailand did and back
out
you
Russians and then we'll go way beyond
these to the lecture next next Tuesday
you